[Música]
este es mi abuelo se llama andrés de
hecho justo por él es que yo me llamo
andrés también es mi abuelo paterno él
era un cirujano de excelente ortopedista
y en sus ratos libres le gustaba pintar
siempre me acuerdo de él cuando era niño
que estaba en la casa y le gustaba hacer
acuarelas de paisajes y caricaturas de
las personas que conocíamos esta es una
de las caricaturas que hizo en los 80s
sobre una vecina
este es uno de los cuadros que hizo que
es un paisaje en acuarela
mi abuela materna también su esposa se
llama ver a ella también era pintora en
sus tiempos libres y ella fue la primera
persona que descubrió que yo tenía la
capacidad para pintar que tenía la
habilidad entonces me acuerdo que desde
pequeño ella le encantaba regalarme
todas las navidades todos los cumpleaños
me regalaba estuches de pinturas de
lápices de colores cuadernos para
dibujar era lo que más me gustaba y me
entretenía horas
este es un cuadro que ya hizo que tiene
en su casa es un bodegón que hizo para
decorar su comedor y esta es una copia
que hice yo cuando tenía cuatro años en
creo que me senté en el comedor copiar
el cuadro que yo hice y entonces éste lo
pinté desde chiquito siempre me gustó
pintar y este fue mi primer cuadro de
hecho y lo tengo enmarcado y mi mamá lo
tiene guardado
este por otro lado por el lado de mi
papá también este había mucha habilidad
para dibujar mi abuelo paterno que nunca
lo conocí porque falleció antes de que
yo naciera él también era pintor y
aunque nunca lo conocí a través de sus
pinturas que están en decorando la casa
de mi abuela pude conocer un poquito de
él él le gustaba pintar paisajes de la
ciudad de méxico- pintó un cuadro una
escena basada en una foto que él tomó
que era una escena de eje central en la
ciudad de mexico donde se ve el tráfico
un día lluvioso la torre latino de fondo
ese cuadro lo hizo en los años 60s y
aunque no lo conocía a partir de ese
cuadro como que pude ver un poquito del
sentí que de alguna variedad había
trascendido entonces desde muy pequeño
aprendí a apreciar el arte crecí
apreciando el arte de hecho hay varias
experiencias que recuerdo cuando era
niño me acuerdo que mis papás todos los
domingos nos llevaban a comer al
restaurante siempre con amigos de ellos
entonces para qué no me aburriera
mientras ellas están platicando y
comiendo
se distancia muy fácil ponerme manteles
de los manteles que ponen de papel o en
los restaurantes son las servilletas y
me acuerdo que me la pasaba horas ahora
el tiempo ahí pintando y me encanta
pintar pintar pintar pintar y luego
también recuerdo que mi papá una vez nos
puso a mi hermana ya mi a dibujar
empezamos a hacer unos dibujos y jugamos
a la galería me creo que ponemos todos
los dibujos que hacíamos así en la sala
en mi casa y hacíamos que mi abuela y mi
mamá los compraran por 10 pesos 15 pesos
a partir de ahí obtuve como mi primer
trabajo como artista puede ser mi abuela
me contrató en el baño del cuarto de mi
abuela me acuerdo que había un vidrio
transparente y mi abuela no veía bien
entonces me contrató para que cada
semana le actualizará los dibujos me
compraba dibujos para pegarlos en el
vídeo porque ya no chocarán y entonces
se fue mi trabajo cada semana me pagaba
10 pesos 20 puestos por hacerle dibujos
también recuerdo que en la biblioteca de
mi casa había una colección de libros
que me encantaba ver cuando era niño era
una gran como 12 de volúmenes de la
historia del arte
entonces yo siendo un niño de 5 o 6 años
me encantaba agarrar el libro y me ponía
a hojearlo y veía todo lo que todos
estos artistas se habían hecho y me
llama muchísimo la atención de hecho
recuerdo muchísimo este cuadro
él es un cuadro que hizo rembrant en el
siglo 17 y me impresionó bastante porque
yo siendo un niño de 5 años nunca en la
vida había visto un cuerpo abierto no
sabía cómo eran y cuando vi este cuadro
me impresionó bastante me hizo sentir
algo y como que fue algo que recuerdo
hasta la fecha bastante
cuando empecé a crecer llegué a la
adolescencia y mi abuela que siempre se
había percatado de que yo tenía la
habilidad para dibujar me metió a clases
de pintura donde a paralelo a la escuela
y en esa escuela en esa clase que estuve
tuve como profesor a un maestro que era
un pintor muy reconocido en esa época me
enseñó todo lo básico este las técnicas
básicas para pintar en esa clase hice
este cuadro que fue también como de mis
primeras obras en el 2013
qué es una copia de un personaje de
miguel ángel de la capilla sixtina que
me encantaba y se lo regalé a mi abuela
actualmente hoy lo tiene puesto en su
sala
estos son algunos de mis cuadros
favoritos en esta clase y además para la
mayoría de mis compañeros es
aburridísima y con la clase más aburrida
para mí era mi favorita y fue la primera
vez que tuve un contacto
con el arte pop
el arte pop para los que algunos a lo
mejor se estaban preguntando qué es el
arte por el arte pop es un movimiento
artístico que empezó en estados unidos y
en inglaterra en los años 60 que se
inspiraba en la vida diaria que eso era
algo novedoso que no había existido
antes en el arte y de alguna manera
hicieron que la artes y se hiciera
accesible a la gente era un arte que
representaba a la sociedad de consumo en
la que actualmente todavía hoy seguimos
viviendo y utilizaba la iconografía de
los medios de comunicación yo siempre
fui súper fan de los cómics de las
caricaturas de las películas entonces no
pude evitar identificarme con este tipo
de arte aún así enamorado del arte nunca
lo considere como una opción para
dedicarme a eso nunca o sea lo veía como
un hobby
tenía 17 años
y nadie me había dicho que podía ser
artista nadie nunca me dijo que era una
opción para vivir
vivimos dentro de un sistema educativo
que nos enseña que el arte existe
pero no nos enseña que es una opción
para vivir no es una opción de empleo es
algo que vemos en los libros y que todos
de alguna manera nos gusta pero hasta
ahí
bueno
y luego pasó prepa
y me metí a la universidad me metí a
estudiar arquitectura al tecnológico de
monterrey y para mí eso era arquitectura
era lo más cercano a hacer algo creativo
que me gustaba de hecho en ese entonces
pensaba dedicarme a hacer sets para
televisión para teatro cine es ahora lo
que quería lograr y era lo que yo veía
crear lo más creativo que podía hacer
que se veía bien que mis papás iban a
ver bien que él es mi familia iba a ver
bien que la gente que me rodeaba lo iba
a aceptar
algo que no consideren cuando estaba
estudiando arquitectura fue que
arquitectura de esporas matemáticas
yo siempre fui pésimo con las
matemáticas pésimo dicen que tenemos una
mitad del cerebro que es creativa y otra
mitad que es matemáticas bueno la mitad
de mi cerebro que es matemático nunca se
desarrolló no sé era pésimo pésimo mi
mamá de hecho les podrá comprar como
toda la vida desde primaria secundaria
preparada vez que tenía un examen de
matemáticas tenemos que contratar a un
profesor un profesor o un tutor para que
me pudiera ayudar a pasar los exámenes y
me ayudaba para pasar el examen y al día
siguiente ya se me había olvidado todo
a ustedes díganme cuando en la vida he
tenido que ver
o resolver algún problema de seno coseno
alguna operación trigonométricas como
esta
fuera de la escuela nunca
aún así me decían que tenía que estudiar
matemáticas porque las ibas a el resto
de la vida que va a ser súper necesario
esto
y aquí pues eso me frustraba porque me
di cuenta que
yo que era una persona creativa estaba
estudiando una carrera que aparentemente
era creativa pero estaba rodeado de
matemáticas que era mi peor debilidad
entonces eso me empezó a frustrar porque
me di cuenta que era malo y me frustraba
porque era soy malo haciendo lo que se
supone que voy a hacer el resto de mi
vida y eso me generaba muchísima
ansiedad
al punto que tuve que salirme de la
escuela y dejar la carrera entonces
llegó el año 2012 que creo que ha sido
el peor año de mi vida ese año y mis
papás se divorciaron y mi familia se
desintegró de alguna manera
mi mamá y mis hermanas se fueron a vivir
a otro país
y yo me quedé aquí solo en mexico y no
estaba en la escuela no tenía trabajo me
tuve que ir a vivir solo no sabía que
iba a ser con mi vida
y pues fue una época de muchísimo
incertidumbre
así que esta época de mi vida de hecho
se llama mi primera crisis existencial
porque fue la primera vez que me empecé
a preguntar qué voy a hacer estaba solo
no sabía que iba a ser no sabía no tenía
claro cuál era mi meta en la vida se
supone que a los 18 años cuando entras a
la universidad ya tienes que saber qué
vas a hacer el resto de tu vida ya
tienes que saber tu vida resuelta ya
tienes que saber todo y yo no sabía nada
estaba muy estresada entonces durante
esa época mientras me encontraba conmigo
mismo
tuve que tomar pues algún trabajo tenía
que sobrevivir entonces tomé una larga
lista de trabajos temporales empecé a
trabajar en un restaurante luego estoy
trabajando de extra en películas trabajé
como asistente personal de un arquitecto
finalmente terminé trabajando en el área
de relaciones públicas para un periódico
y fue durante esta época de mucha
incertidumbre
que me di cuenta que necesitaba pintar
siempre me había gustado pintar pero los
últimos años lo había descuidado por
estar preocupado en que iba a hacer con
mi vida entonces empecé a sentir una
necesidad por pintar nuevamente
y comencé a pintar justo el departamento
donde vivía en ese entonces todas las
paredes estaban vacías y empecé a sentir
una necesidad de tener colores alrededor
mío de poder alegrarme de alguna manera
y entonces empecé a pintar
quería que todo estuviera lleno de color
y justo en ese momento cuando empecé a
pintar me di cuenta que toda mi vida a
pesar de que había tenido muchísimos
cambios en todos los aspectos de mi vida
lo única cosa que se había permanecido
intacta era mi amor por el arte no eso
nunca había cambiado hoy no me había
dado cuenta hasta ese momento
y me di cuenta que cuando pintaba era
feliz
esta frase me gusta mucho es una frase
de oscar wilde que dice a veces podemos
pasar años sin vivir en lo absoluto y de
pronto toda nuestra vida se concentra en
un solo instante eso fue lo que sentí en
ese momento de repente en un solo
momento también se concentró hoy y era
como que voy a hacer que voy a hacer
entonces empecé a pintar esta es una
foto no es mi mejor foto pero bueno es
una época que refleja mucho esa época
cuando empecé a pintar cuadros para
llenar el departamento inicialmente
estos cuadros eran para mí era para
decorarlo era para yo alegrarme
y en el departamento de cuadros de
repente ya todo estaba así y la gente se
empezó a dar cuenta siempre tenía
invitados siempre había gente los fines
de semana y mis amigos empezaron a dar
cuenta y a percatarse de mi talento
y les gustaba empecé a darme cuenta que
les gustaba entre ellos había una chica
que era muy amiga mía que trabajaba en
la oficina en ese entonces en mi trabajo
godín que me llevaba muy bien con ella y
una vez fue al estudio y me dice oye
tengo un amigo que es un amigo de ella
que era cantante que lo invitaron a un
evento que es el 10 aniversario de su
productora
y está buscando un regalo que le quiere
regalar a su productor pero no sabe qué
regalarle 3 que lo pueda traer aquí a la
casa y pláticas con él y yo por supuesto
entonces fue
y me dijo quiero hacer un regalo
especial para el productor que tenía una
muy buena relación con él y mi hijo
quiero hacer un cuadro ver si me puedes
hacer un cuadro con la imagen de él yo
creo que va a ser algo especial y algo
que pues nadie le va a regalar
resulta que este productor es martin
terefe
él es el productor de kirchner town
récords en londres que de hecho es el
mismo productor de músicos como coldplay
o abel y resultó que el cuadro iba a ser
un regalo para él entonces pues me
emocioné demasiado
y fue mi primer cuadro ese fue el primer
cuadro que vendí
y eso fue lo que necesitaba como para
motivarme un poquito porque a partir de
esa experiencia de haber vendido este
cuadro fue cuando por primera vez en la
vida me hice la pregunta más loca que me
he hecho
qué tal si dejas todo lo que estás
haciendo y te dedicas a ser pintor lo
que más te gusta
fue como si todo en ese momento me di
cuenta que fue como si todo lo que
hubiera hecho en mi vida que yo pensaba
que muchas cosas no habían servido pero
fue como si cada dibujo que había hecho
en mi niñez cada libro que había leído
cada experiencia buena mala a todos los
cursos que tomé en el tec de cómo ser
emprendedor todo todo lo que había hecho
en mi vida me había preparado para ese
momento sino darme cuenta toda mi vida
me había estado preparando para tomar
esa decisión sin yo ni siquiera saberlo
y tenía miedo porque era como si no
funciona si a la gente no le gusta lo
que hago si no compran cuadros y solo
hago el ridículo
pero la en ese momento ya no tenía mucho
que perder y tenía mucho que ganar así
que pues me valió y me arriesgue
entonces fue cuando me di cuenta que yo
tenía una herramienta muy poderosa que
no tenía ninguno de los pintores que
estaba estudiando me van gogh ni
velázquez ni siquiera andy warhol habían
tenido que era las redes sociales
en mi celular
así que decidí abrir un instagram y
empezar a documentar cómo era mi
evolucionó como me convertí como era que
me iba a convertir en un artista y lo
decidí compartir con la gente así que me
animé y seguir pintando
seguí pintando
y seguir pintando en el año 2015 tuve mi
primera exposición individual con mi
familia mis amigos en el año 2016 tuve
mi segunda exposición que se llamó retro
pop que fue la primera exposición que
tuve enfrente de medios y que ya era
abierta al público donde ya oficialmente
le eche a todos voy a ser pintor
hoy ya pasaron siete años desde el día
que me puse tres meses de límite para
pintar que dije si en tres meses no lo
logro pues ya ni modo busco un trabajo
en una oficina o veo qué hago pero bueno
esos tres meses llegaron al límite y hoy
llevo siete años desde ese momento y no
he parado de pintar todos los días
y yo creo que la razón por la que de
alguna manera me ha ido bien
construyendo esta carrera como pintor no
fue tanto porque yo fuera el mejor
pintor o el más innovador sino fue por
diferentes puntos que les quiero
platicar primero que nada ven si el
miedo suena fácil pero la mayoría de la
gente se queda en el miedo mucha gente
yo creo que todos ustedes tienen sueños
tienen metas quieren lograr algo pero
muchas personas no se arriesgan y se
prefieren quedar en la comodidad de una
zona de confort
y luego generar oportunidades yo creo
que todos tenemos la capacidad de
provocar nuestras propias oportunidades
y todos tenemos el poder en nuestras
manos de ser un cambio por nuestras
vidas y luchar por lo que queremos y por
nuestros sueños
otra cosa que también me sirvió bastante
fue el no adoptar la seguridad las
inseguridades de las demás personas no
saben cuántas personas me han dicho vas
a ser pintor te vas a morir de hambre
qué vas a hacer y osa porque no buscas
un trabajo serio yo así usted es pintor
no es un trabajo serios a todos estos
artistas que he leído que están en los
libros de historia no eran personas
serias o sea era un hobby ok
otra cosa
es este
hacer sacrificios yo creo que como
emprendedor y si alguien interesa
emprender tiene que estar dispuesto a
hacer sacrificios si no hacemos
sacrificios y no sacrificamos cosas por
las cosas que queremos hacer y por
nuestros sueños luego nuestros sueños
terminan siendo el sacrificio
y desde el principio yo lo supe yo supe
que desde que tome esta decisión no iba
a ser un camino fácil y que esto es sólo
el principio
tarde casi 25 años en descubrir quién
era y en darme cuenta de lo que vine a
hacer y de lo que llamo es mi misión
como ser como artista
hoy ya sé que quiero que mi vida sea una
aventura y quiero invertir lo que queda
de mi vida tratando de convertirme yo
luchar y tratar de hacer todo lo posible
por convertirme en algunos de esos
artistas que leia cuando era niño en los
libros de historia del arte hoy más que
nunca sé que quiero crear arte y eso es
lo que me motiva y lo que hace que mi
corazón lata todos los días y si con mi
trabajo logró trascender de alguna
manera y tocar las vidas de otras
personas si a través de un cuadro de una
foto de un vídeo logró hacer que una
persona se cuestione que sienta algo que
se inspiré
entonces así sabré que mi vida fue un
éxito
yo soy javier andrés muchas gracias
[Aplausos]